- The prince wants to trade
Andrew Hall for a high value
Jihadist prisoner.
You told us this piece
of [muted] was dead.
I told you he
was taken care of.
Big changes up north in the
Panski Gorge close to Chechnya.
We keep a light footprint, low
visibility, civilian clothes.
Prince, a Navy SEAL--
The last thing you'll see
before you die is my face.
--what's it matter
who shoots me?
The prince is smart.
He won't kill you,
not right away.
Convince him to keep you
alive, to run you back into us.
And be your spy?
It's your only option.
You want me dead.
No.
I want the prince.
(ON PHONE) Halojena, that
was my favorite school.
Exchange, Tom.
We're here.
Where are you?
The exchange has been moved
75 kilometers north, northeast
of the village of Chero.
Chero's on the Chechen border.
He's laying a trap.
It's starting.
(ON WALKIE) Delta
1, [inaudible]
we arrived on a possible
transport two clicks away.
Grid to follow.
Next com window in four hours.
Haber One, out.
- That's our transpo.
(ON WALKIE) Foxtrot
Delta One, the Georgians
are pulling drone coverage.
Proceed as planned.
No Georgia QRF, no drones.
Fair.
We are walking into a trap.
You know this, I know this,
damn, [inaudible] knows it.
What the hell are we doing?
We're doing our jobs.
You're not seals.
You're lobsters, getting
boiled one degree at a time
until it's too late to
crawl out the prince's pot.
Ask her.
This is personal.
Look, he's right.
It is personal, OK,
just like it is for you.
The real man responsible for
Taggart's death is the prince.
And if we want payback,
we've got to get him.
And I need your
help, all of you.
You want to try?
Wow.
So we're having a daddy,
daughter moment, huh?
- I guess we are.
- (ECHOING) Dad?
Dad?
I'm fine.
You know what your problem is?
You might want to get in line.
Summit Fever.
Summit Fever is--
Yeah, I know what
Summit Fever is.
When you get close to the
top down and then the weather
rolls in, the real weather,
hardest thing to do
is walk away.
We should walk away.
Trust me, Ricky, I
won't lead you astray.
Nazim, he's bait, right?
So I guess the question
is, for whose trap,
yours or the prince's.
I need you you
can handle Ortiz.
Look, we've
buddies a long time,
so he's going to do his job.
You can't command
buddies, Graves.
You want to lead, you can't
be friends with any of them.
Hey, Bear, we got
a situation up here.
Christ.
Stop right there.
Go ahead, get your pay back.
It won't matter.
You, your family, all
of you are dead already.
Mom?
Jesus.
Mom.
If I die, a trigger
gets pulled on all of you,
the same as Taggart.
Why do you have a gun, Mom?
Take me back.
I'll make a call.
Take your families off the list.
Hold, Nazri, you
pulled your one trigger,
Taggart, your personal payback.
There is no [inaudible]
- Bull[muted].
You never caught a shooter.
My people don't need orders.
They're still in place
stalking your families.
Call it off, and I'll
take you down there myself.
Take me down there first.
[inaudible] He's bluffing.
Let's move out.
The hand-off is in three hours.
Your family is safe, Ortiz.
This is it.
The village is 5
kilometers up that valley.
Hey, Bear, village must be
Kishnet which is in Chechnya.
The prince wants us
to walk into Russia.
We don't to do it, boys.
Look, this is what we do.
We take risks and
we follow orders.
We got to go now.
Rip, we don't go.
He would put a bullet
in Nazri's his head
and take us home
back to our families.
I'm not Rip.
Might as well see
what happens next.